simplement
j'ai pas l'impression d'être un sénateur
particulier mais j'ai pas non plus
l'impression d'être hors du temps et
pour reprendre ce que disait de nos
collègues tout à l'heure je veux bien
être le site de le sénateur représentant
les plus grandes filiales que la terre
est portée ou que la terre porte que
notre pays porte aujourd'hui il s'agit
pas de savoir si on veut continuer
travailler mais c'est de savoir si on
peut continuer de travailler après 62
ans et ne me dites pas de bêtises ne me
dites pas de bêtises quand vous avez
commencé de travailler tôt ou même pas
obligatoirement tôt mais pendant 20 ans
30 ans 35 ans vous avez travaillé dans
dans le froid dans les intempéries
apporter des charges lourdes à partir de
60 ans à partir de 62 ans vous êtes
éreinté fatigué laminé vous n'existez
plus physiquement et vous dites que l'on
peut encore continuer de travailler deux
ans supplémentaires et tout à l'heure le
collègue sénateur je regardais sa page
wikipédia j'ai pas réussi à trouver son
travail mais je pense pas qu'il ait
travaillé avec ses mains pendant 40 ans
pour avoir cet avis là et pensez aussi
aux personnes que vous applaudissiez
tous que nous tous à 20h il y a deux ans
les soignants les infirmières les
médecins les aides-soignantes les ash
comment vous pouvez oser les regarder
encore aujourd'hui et vous Mesdames et
Messieurs les médecins quand vous les
recevez dans vos cabinets que vous que
qu'est-ce que vous leur dites quant à 62
ans les les aides-soignantes vous dites
vous disent mais moi je peux plus faire
les transferts des personnes âgées du
brancard à un lit parce que j'ai le dos
cassé j'ai les bras cassés j'ai les
épaules cassés vous leur dites quoi vous
leur dites bah écoutez vous allez quand
même faire deux ans supplémentaires
c'est ça mais comment vous pouvez tenir
de tels propos comment pouvez-vous ne
pas être d'accord avec nous quand nous
disons que pour ces gens-là pas pour
tout le monde pas pour tout le monde moi
maintenant aujourd'hui je peux tout à
fait travailler jusqu'à 64 ans jusqu'à
65 ans rassurez-vous c'est bien moins
pénible d'être ici même jusqu'à 2h du
matin à 3h du matin 4h du matin que
faire paysan ou travailler dans le
bâtiment rassurez-vous moi j'ai fait
tous ces métiers là et je peux vous
garantir que ces métiers là le rendu
plan anti-âge de la tête vous achetez de
la tête chers collègues sénateur mais
vous savez très bien que j'ai raison
vous avez très bien comment propose
merci